all together it's the members of the
Libya committee the members of the
subcommittee on human rights
chair
Bullman most welcome
and Committee of development represented
here by vice president Mercedes bresso
please just allow me to to welcome you
to to this
exchange of views
of us three committees together
in order to to deal with the with the
issue of our concern shared concern
refugees
marking World Refugee day where the
spotlight on forgotten crisis in line
with unscr team for this year Well
Refugee day which focuses on the power
of inclusion and solutions for refugees
I'm just reminding you by the way that
in the premises of the European
Parliament there is an ongoing
exhibition
which was hosted by three distinguished
MEPS in this house
Monica Gonzalez Stefan Bijou and uh if
I'm pronouncing it right
which are which are doing it together uh
with the unscr was uh presented
yesterday solemnly with the presence of
a vice president
uh leonardig of the commission on
on the commissioner on the on this on
this uh most relevant uh and delegate
issue of our shared concern
we are presenting here the opportunity
to to engage in a talk
uh on this
fear of underlying and intertwined
conflicts that have been just
reignited by by the pandemic uh
goes on with with with climate change
extreme weather desertification all the
problems that are involved environmental
demographic
economic and social challenges which are
lying ahead
and
without further delay
I'm announcing that there are some
guests that have been
uh invited to take the floor
Mr bahati Maisie see I know how to
pronounce it agreeing to share his
experience of displacement as a refugee
as the impact education has about
throughout all of his life originally
from the
Democratic Republic of Congo Refugee in
Zimbabwe since 2003
joining us remotely from Italy
where he's completing a master's degree
now
then it'll be Mrs Jasmine Rockefeller
chief of global issues of unhcr Brussels
absolutely essential international
organization in this area
and Mr Francesco Luciani head of unit
for migration and forth displacement of
Digi inpa of the commission and finally
Mrs esterposor
which is also from
from the commission head of a Asylum
unit of tiki home
but I I will simply invite my My
co-chairs Dear Miss espresso and to say
some words before we proceed please
thank you
I will speak in Italian so if you need
the headphone
well
thank you very much
chairman and I'd like to welcome you on
behalf of the development committee
as
has been recalled with this exchange of
views we're celebrating World Refugee
day now
we currently have 108 million people who
are forcibly displaced across the world
and around 35 million of those are
refugees the rest are internally
displaced and learn middle-income
countries host 76 percent
of the world's refugees and it's also
because of that that it's important and
relevant
for our committee to be involved in this
meeting
now the International Community
recognizes migration as a key issue for
the 23rd development of the un's 2030
agenda
but in spite of that the numbers of
refugees and the time they remain as
refugees continues to increase many
people refugees for long periods of time
and they face major economic and life
challenges so we need to focus our
efforts to deal with the Deep causes
that force people to leave their homes
and create conditions that can
contribute to stability and prosperity
in people's country of origin we're
committed to supporting refugees
internally displaced people and the
communities that host them and to work
for Sustainable Solutions particularly
when it comes to forgotten crisis of
which Seas of which there are many
humanitarian assistance is significant
but it can't be the only solution we
need to take a three-fold approach as a
set out in the Nexus now I'd like to
know from the commission how they are
ensuring that displaced uh forcibly
displaced people are included in our
development work and I look forward to
hearing from Mr minchu who originally
comes from the DLC and who has been a
refugee in Zimbabwe since 2003.
we know that the DRC hosts one of the
largest populations of displaced people
in the world estimated to be between
five and a half and 6.3 million people I
also look forward to hearing from
Leon HCR which I've always supported
also personally
I look forward to hearing how they can
tell us hearing them tell us how we can
support uh refugees and Refugee
communities to improve their resilience
and their self-sufficiency so thank you
very much I give the floor to Mr Bullman
now please
thank you very much dear colleagues dear
guests it's good that we come together
on a day like that
we have to remember the
1951 Geneva Refugee convention and the
1967 protocol are the cornerstones
of the international legal protection
framework for all refugees
legal protection that means that
refugees have rights
in their country of Refuge freedom of
movements right to an education
access to courts and write to a family
life
a right to live in dignity
but once talking about refugees
on a day like that we also should not be
silent
on the quality of border regimes
because
the life of refugees is determined
by the way in which we welcome or not
you know the current debates
you know the position of the council we
will deal with that
hopefully in the
good spirit
proper way
colleagues are prepared
but let us not stop
dream about borders
as places where people meet
where they can exchange experience where
they can learn from it each other and
not think of
borders as fences
where you are rejected
and where you feel aggression and Hate
we should work on this dream as
Europeans
last but not least
be an ongoing discussions and yesterday
with the respective commissioner
we are shocked by
U.N reports
giving us insights on the fact
that obviously
still practices of pushbacks
are acted out
in the Mediterranean U.N report speak
about
the practices of the Libyan Coast Guard
but also about the issue that European
institutions are involved from Texas
involved
and let us promise colleagues on a day
like that on the world Refugee day
that we clarify on that
and that we are not
silent
on malpractices and try to change that
according
to our legal Provisions which have to be
defended thank you very much
thank you so much now let's get started
the discussion thank you thank you it's
been
actually very very
moving because it's it's very
intentional the way we are
discussing World Refugee days with the
with the right interlocution with the
with the with the right guest speakers
which are about to start to share with
us their their testimonies we'll get
started with Mr Ming C I understand
that's the way
we could pronounce it Mr mincy from
remote from Italy seven minutes to you
are you connected yes you are go ahead
welcome welcome to our committee
thank you uh DHS
honorable members of the European Union
of the European Parliament
I was only nine years old when my whole
world was shattered and I became a
refugee
I was playing on the banks of Lake
Tanganyika near the village we called
home
my brother Kinga was fishing nearby and
my sister Molly was washing the dishes
in the waters of the lake
all of a sudden gunshots ripped through
the quiet afternoon
I ran to my siblings
and we hid behind some borders
but the shots continued
it was the beginning of the kivu
conflict which till this day continues
to ravage EastEnders
the armed conflict there has displaced
millions of people over the past two
decades
for a while we hid amidst the Rocks too
scared to move
but after a bit
we got up the courage to run home
everyone else in the village was running
in the opposite direction
they were racing towards the lake
in hopes of escaping on the bus that we
normally use to travel
from one Village to another
but we needed to find our family
when we go to our house it was empty
our parents and two of other siblings
were nowhere to be found
I still remember how alone and scared I
felt at that moment
without my parents my 17 year old
brother took charge
he saw we had no choice but to escape
along with our neighbors
we ran back to the lake with nothing
more than the clothes on our back and
squeezed onto one of the boats
the boat headed south
the Deep Waters of Lake Tanganyika the
world's longest lake stretched out
infinitely before us
we sold for days
traveling roughly the distance between
Brussels and Geneva
my brother my sister and I disembarked
in Zambia
we were reeling from trauma
we knew no one and had no idea where to
go and what to do
as we were searching for something to
eat
a contract driver pity us
and smuggled us across the board of
Zimbabwe where we were eventually given
a refugee status
while we were really relieved to be in a
safe place
we struggled to move forward with our
lives
I just wanted to be regular kid and go
to school
having lost my home my parents and most
of my siblings
school was the only place where I could
imagine finding hope again
but scrapping together the money for
school fees was a huge obstacle my
siblings and I were living in a refugee
camp where relied on food Aid
my brother was determined to provide us
more than Omega rations
he was also determined to secure us a
ticket to a brighter future
he worked tirelessly toiling all hours
at all jobs outside the camp
he spent all of his earnings on extra
food and enrolled my sister and me in
school
in a word my brother sacrifices his own
future to provide us as a primary school
boy named University
I was up I was very proud of my
achievement
and I'm especially proud today at the
age of 29 knowing that just six out of
every 100 refugees managed to make it to
University by comparison 40 percent of
non-refugee Youth attend University
worldwide
but my family's financial problems meant
that no matter how hard I studied my
academic future was up in the air
after my second year in college I owe
but lost hope being able to complete my
degree because we could no longer afford
the fees
at that very that moment came in the
form of Daffy scholarship
which helps promising Refugee students
attend University in their host
countries
a similar initiative today
has allowed me to continue my studies
Beyond where I thought possible
thanks to Unique program
that helps Refugee attend universities
in Italy I'm now pursuing master's
degree in global management and politics
at Lewis University in Rome
but education is not only about getting
a degree
particularly for refugees for us school
offers more than knowledge
it's a place to make new friends and
heal Old Wounds
it's a place to discover hidden talents
and Forge radiant destinies
because I got the chance to study my own
future looks bright
I hope to make the most of what I've
learned to give back to the communities
that welcomed me and to continue to
advocate for others like me
none of these would have been possible
without my brother is tireless work and
tenacity propelled me from a tent in a
refugee camp
a university lecture hall
but it shouldn't be that way
no Refugee child should depend on blind
luck or a guardian angel
all Refugee children wherever they are
should have the opportunity to study
just like you
all Refugee children deserve the chance
to become the best possible versions of
themselves
according to Mandela education is the
most powerful weapon which we can use to
change the world
I thank you
thank you we thank you
[Applause]
it is us to thank you and I think that
warm Round of Applause
actually means that we celebrate that
you made it we're happy to have you here
Among Us
as a European you belong
thank you
for your testimony
and now we hear from Mrs drockenfeller
if you are live with us the floor is
yours
thank you chair
to your chairs to your colleagues
honorable members of the European
Parliament
thank you for having me here and thank
you Mr bahati minisi
for sharing your experience
so important
that legislators hear Refugee voices
like yours
your story is inspiring
but sadly it's also the exception
too few refugees manage to unlock
similar opportunities to thrive
particularly those who find themselves
caught up in forgotten crisis
that have long since fallen out of
global headlines
having a Frank discussion and dialogue
with the EU
about the situation
of those forced to flee globally
helps to shift the focus back
to where needs are and where Solutions
lie
Solutions were also the theme of this
year's World Refugee day
already mentioned earlier
2022 so the highest number forcibly
displaced people ever recorded 108
million people including Palestinians
under unras mandate
in 2023 we will likely see even more
people forced to flee from Ukraine
Sudan
Afghanistan and the DRC
driving the numbers further up
this is particularly devastating
considering that most of them find
themselves hosted in low and
middle-income countries
that means actually that most of the
responsibility for responding to force
displacement is being shouldered by the
countries that can least afford it
and mostly by immediate Neighbors
for example in Lebanon one out of three
inhabitants is a refugee
the eu's response to the Ukraine
situation has been nothing short of
exemplary
and there is much to be learned
from Europe's experience of welcoming
refugees
the activation of the temporary
protection directive is an extraordinary
example of solidarity
it has proven many political statements
wrong actually that Europe is full that
there is no space for relocation or
increased resettlement that there is no
public support for refugees
the negotiation of the new pact provides
an important opportunity to ensure that
the same treatment
shown to those fleeing Ukraine is
applied to anyone seeking Asylum
regardless of the origin
whether this is inside or outside
Europe's borders
and irrespective
of whether this is high or low on the
political agenda
my role here is to draw your attention
to forgotten crisis that need it most to
name a few Bangladesh Colombia Lebanon
Chad and Yemen they're protracted forced
displacement situations that receive
insufficient International Aid
they also often lay out far from the
Medias and the Public's attention
we need EU leadership
to change this and engage in dialogue
with these countries
we need the EU to adapt its financing
tools to fit the reality of mobile
populations
and we need the EU to share its lessons
with host countries
to ensure no one is Left Behind as we
progress towards the sustainable
development goals these countries
desperately need solidarity and support
as any piece you can play a crucial role
in making that happen
here are six concrete areas the European
Parliament can make a real difference in
the lives of refugees and communities
that host them with which and which are
out of the spotlight so one is about
flexibility
the use funding mechanism must be become
more flexible
when emergencies hit unhcr and our
partner organizations often find
ourselves on the front lines of volatile
situations as it stands the commission
has among the world's most tightly
earmarked budgets
earmarking prevents us from shifting
funds to meet unfolding needs and
hamstrings our ability to provide
life-saving Aid to those who need it
most
the European Parliament has been the
strongest advocate for flexible funding
we're encouraged by the recent Council
conclusions and call on you to work with
the council and the commission towards
finding concrete ways to making the eu's
budget agile
second transparency
the U is already taking a leading role
in promoting Global solidarity it is one
of few donors that have adopted
Progressive financial instruments such
as the ndk
with its 10 spending Target for
migration and forced displacement
however to date it is impossible to
fully track
how much for what purpose and where the
EU will have spent these 10 percent
or to differentiate
between force displacement and migration
this must be reported on transparently
to the European Parliament the council
and all other relevant stakeholders the
oecd tracking system
on financing for Force displacement
we'll assess each DAC member's
contribution to responsibility sharing
which is an excellent opportunity for
the EU to Showcase its support to Global
solidarity and to meaningfully report on
its spending
political leverage and the midterm
review
number three
many countries experience both internal
displacement and hosting refugees
the EU has a golden opportunity at its
disposal the national envelopes of the
andiki the multi-indicative
programs these envelopes allow for
political leverage with affected
countries
to adopt inclusive policies
better protection as well as Solutions
the midterm review poses an opportunity
to bring forced displacement higher on
the EU sectoral priorities
and I call on you in your important
oversight role to help adjust the EU
National development envelopes to better
reflect Global solidarity beyond the
eu's borders unhcr with its protection
and Deep Field expertise stands ready
to guide the EU on how to make the
sectoral envelopes fit for purpose
development and Peace by default also
this was mentioned most displacement
situations and forgotten crises are
protected
think Syria Venezuela Afghanistan and
Myanmar as well as most situations in
sub-Saharan Africa humanitarian response
cannot lift countries out of Crisis
alone
development and peace need to come in
right from the outset root causes need
to be better understood and addressed
your support to ensure coordination
harmonization of EU and member states
instruments in the spirit of the triple
Nexus will be critical
fifth it's a little bit longer sorry
resettlement
EU investment and support should not
stop at providing political and
financial support to these countries
within its programming it should strive
towards Solutions
unhcr estimates that more than 2 million
refugees are in need of resettlement in
2023 which is about half a million more
compared to 2022. unhcr's Target is to
resettle hundred thousand refugees in
2023 and 110 000 in 2020 24.
that you must rise to the occasion and
commit to at least 30 percent of these
admissions each year and finally six
education
Listening to bahati We heard the power
of Education to change the refugees life
in fact nearly half of all Refugee
children do not attend school at all and
only six percent gain access to tertiary
education
it's crucial we work together to break
down those barriers that are keeping
them out of classrooms and universities
access to education can be a powerful
tool of complementary Pathways allowing
refugees to not just survive but to
thrive the EU has repeatedly
demonstrated its willingness to lead by
example and be a decisive player in
reaching this goal today I call you to
be Advocates to ensure that the EU
continues to invest in Refugee education
at all levels for example by including
refugees into Erasmus Plus and supported
initiatives such as the Daffy
scholarship program
like bahati is participating in
your chairs honorable members of
parliament the 1951 Refugee convention
and the EU were born from the same
tragedy
both aim to save future Generations from
the devastation wrought by War
the strength of both is found not only
in a Resolute legal basis for preventing
conflict and protecting people but also
and just as importantly
in a deeper sense of solidarity
no one chose to be a refugee thank you
for your time
absolutely we thank you
we thank you too we've heard we've heard
too much compelling testimonies for sure
but we're about to hear a third
we thank you Mr Rockefeller now we hear
from Mr Luciani
Mr Luciani the floor is yours for the
next six minutes
um
good morning and honorable members of
the European Parliament at the
distinguished cast
and the fellow colleagues on this
momentous occasion of the world Refugee
Day come together to reflect on on how
we can join forces to face the global
challenge of the forces placement that
has reached an unprecedented level of
gravity
how can Development actors of safety and
hope to their millions of refugees
internally displaced persons Asylum
Seekers and Status looking to rebuild
the lives how can we Foster durable
Solutions
as has been recalled while Europe is
receiving and hosting million of
refugees nevertheless the longer the
larger quantity of of a person in need
of international protection and
internationally internally displaced
persons are hosted in fragile low-income
countries that are frequently also
exposed to the additional challenges of
insecurity and climate displacement and
climate change
they they bear the burden of hosting and
supporting millions of displaced a
person that often face limited access to
basic Services economic opportunities
and protection and all this further
contributes to their marginalization and
the fragility of the host communities
and additionally the presence of large
displaced population can strain social
cohesion exaggerate underlying ethnic or
sectarian tensions and potentially fuel
further conflicts
addressing forces placement requires
addressing underlining causes of
fragility and promoting a compensate
response where Urban Italian development
and peace actors join efforts
the European Union is the firefront of
the respiratory response this is well
known
colleagues of DJ Echo are not in this
room at this moment uh I will focus on
the uh development response that within
the commission Services director General
International partnership and
for neighborhood and enlargement are are
in in charge of providing
notably through the global Europe fund
where indeed the indicative 10 percent
spending Target is supposed to call that
not simply migration but also Force
displacement
the use of development funds for uh
responding to force displacement
is a reality since many years
and the European Union was at the fair
front of strategy the importance to use
development funds to that direction in
addition to the humanitarian
uh this started with the adoption on a
policy based on the inclusion uh on on
uh on the basis of the commission uh
communication presented in 2016 uh on uh
life's in dignity from eight dependence
to self-reliance that almost anticipated
the the concept that then expressed
through the global compact on refugees
where the main objective was to ensure
that forces placement uh does not become
protracted or uh at least if it is
protracted it it is helped to be
transformed into from the the dependency
on American assistant into a social and
professional inclusion and durable
Solutions at local level or through
resettlement or repatriation whenever
possible
um the global Europe fund
tatas is the main Tool uh for uh VG
implant engineer within the commission
services to address for special
situations
uh in just two years from the start of
its implementation in in the summer 2021
we are now in summer 2023 has already
been uh massively mobilized for forces
placement situations and that includes
both uh supporting refugees and those
communities internet displaced people uh
as well as also trying whenever possible
to address root causes of forces
placement
uh for
um an overall amount that is Beyond two
uh billion euros if we take into account
the actions that have already been
adopted and the thoughts that have been
put by the equation services in the
pipeline in view of adoption
um it is includes indeed the actions in
uh from from Latin America and the
Caribbean region into sub-Saharan Africa
to the North Africa to Asia and
including also the support to Syria
refugees in Turkey
um
funds are
supporting uh as we said the refugee and
idps communities or their host
communities
and mostly help them to have access to
social services such Education Health or
to self-reliance activities or to
enhance the capacities of those
communities to uh provide access to
Social Services
avoiding that us communities are
destabilized by the presence of the so
many new arrivals
the
the policy aiming at supporting uh
refugees and idps has been also
progressively enriched and expanded
recently also with an increased
attention to persons that are displaced
in relation to climate change or
environmental degradation this is a
topic at which we are also increasingly
attentive the European Union is since
July last year the chair of the platform
for disaster displacement and we are
very much working with all uh other
stakeholders in integrating the climate
Dimension into the Nexus work
also because indeed that there is a
vicious circle of fragility that is is
uh is triggered by the presence of
insecurity the presence of humanitarian
situations
we do all this uh well and finance with
acquisition for refugees we are doing
this through share information through
uh exchanging views and also through
deep Dives we are focusing today uh on
uh Democratic Republic of Congo case and
this is uh by chance a country where
myself with Mrs Rockefeller and the
leading two missions we have done uh
this exactly we do uh joint Mission and
the discussion also to more closely
understand how we can better mobilize
the resources available and how we can
we identify better priorities
um
the uh the to respond also to a question
that has been raised in a previous
intervention uh internally displaced
people are also at the very center of
our attention and notably we do our best
in the programming exercise to ensure
that
their presence and their specific needs
are taken into account notably in all
programs that are aimed at enhancing
their uh at the access of citizens of
the beneficiary countries to Social
Services education and on Earth
actions is focused on a number of
counties as I said we operate from
Colombia and Peru where Venezuela
Refugee crisis is at the center of the
story up to the rohingya situation in
Bangladesh so cases are very different
also depending on the reaction by the
authorities of the countries that in
some cases are have a very inclusive
approach in other cases
except only an income policy
and we try to push forward in order to
have uh
um openness it was a
social inclusion of the refugees that's
is the approach that the EU promotes
implements at home and promotes all over
the world
but we need in some cases also to adapt
ourselves to the situation policy
situation we face
the presentation could be different from
County to Country if we zoom into the
situation of the Democratic Republic of
Congo which is indeed uh of top
importance at Africa level one and at
Global level for the combination of more
than half a million of refugees and
6 million and Beyond internally
displaced persons
we have are operating in in close
combination with the colleagues dealing
with material assistance and we have
been
focusing on three main
priority areas first to support the
sustainable economic opportunities
improving livelihoods
notably through access to vocational
training programs entrepreneurship
development and access to finance for
small business
the second area has been as mentioned
earlier supporting access to basic
services and social protection
and the third one uh ensuring protection
and having a strengthened governance and
security for all of them particularly
also for internet displaced persons
in the case of the Democratic Republic
of Congo as you know hello on refugees
is established and the system is
relatively stable
but in the case of the internal
dispatched person
work is still to be done the country has
recently domesticated the Kampala
convention but many actions still are
needed in order to ensure that the
government as a real follow-up on the
specific needs of the internet displaced
process beyond the
action that you may proceed to your end
because what I've seen in the timing for
the presentations and there should be
some ground for discussion we thank you
absolutely I conclude by saying that the
action is also at Regional level and
also we support the approach that has
been launched by the commissioner
foreign
we work with them in and again it's an
old continents I conclude by saying that
the commission is preparing for the
second edition of the global Revenue
forum which will be an important moment
for the European Union to reform its
strong support to refugees and the
roasting communities and for demonstrate
all the important mobilization of
resources at policy level and financial
level that we have been doing until now
and we intend to continue thank you
we thank you too we thank you three of
course
and Genie who was the first of our guest
speakers but I guess that should be now
the time for the members to
show their views and share them
loud I suggest a first round of
speaking time for every political group
I understand that it'll be one minute
and a half each if you may there would
be yes sure
would you like to take the floor on your
behalf of Epp please do it
one minute and a half it's a thank you
very much
I I would like to speak to in Polish
why are we dealing with these uh
forgotten con conflicts or forgotten
humanitarian crisis currently help or
even humanitarian policy is not based on
a real scale of a crisis but what the
media on the media attention if the
conflict is long and the media has no
new information to communicate they stop
talking about a given event and this
makes people and even organizations
which do not get new information about
the conflict start forgetting about them
especially in the face of a new disaster
or a new world as you know on the border
between Poland and Belarus for two years
we've had we've had a momentarian crisis
nothing has changed and unfortunately
the media is not as active there as they
used to be therefore I always have
questions and a surprise from other
people that there still is a crisis
going on there is one more aspect here
of course the media were not being able
to not being led to
um report about this conflict because
this conflict was supposed to be
forgotten it was not supposed to be
presented in the media so that the
citizens do not think and do not care
about those who die in the forests On
the Border this is why our humanitarian
policy should be based on real
measures and not on media attention
humanitarian policy should also focus on
creating human Awareness on the real
scale of the crisis and it should have
the tools to direct the interests of the
media to these areas which are starting
to be forgotten only in this way the
policy of the EU will create the
interest of the media the media and not
the other way around thank you
thank you so much
now for the snd maybe Isabel Santos
in Portuguese those that needs earphones
please
um
first of all I'd like to thank you for
this opportunity
to say that it is very important to hold
this debate at a time when the EU is
preparing to approve many legal
instruments in support of our migratory
policy
which will then influence
all of our migratory uh policy now
these are not the instruments that we
wanted to have on the table
but they are now possible after years of
complete paralysis in the search for
solutions that were never found
however they will not
give a an answer to um
a multitude of problems that are only
getting worse
in different parts of the world
displacements last longer because
conflicts are also lasting longer
and the level
needed to respond to these displacements
is not the same as a short-term
displacement
all of this
the conflicts and these long-term
displacements
on top of all this we see another set of
force displacements which is everything
having to do with the climate issue
and we really don't have an answer to
that
it's very important to rethink
the about the humanitarian Aid given by
the EU
and it is important that that
humanitarian Aid keep in mind that many
countries are losing entire Generations
the younger Generations are completely
lost in refugee camps where they don't
have access
to a normal life in a community
where they don't have proper access to a
schooling and where many of them
don't even have any
hopes of of actually being educated I
was in Lebanon last week and I could see
on the ground the situation of many
young people who wish to study who
would like to go to university but they
simply are no conditions for them to go
to university because they can barely
survive and if they go to university
they won't be able to uh to actually
work because they don't have access to
the job market
so we need to ensure
proper life cycle for all these people
and this is all linked to the
Investments that we make
and in the way in which these
Investments are used
the fact that we delegate humanitarian
Aid often means this Aid is very
expensive and money that should go to
the people who need it is actually
in reality
being used to keep going a situation
that we shouldn't be feeding into so
it's a lot of food for thought thank you
we only have half an hour to go and
there are many of you listed and it's
after all it's three committees and I
should also mind the representatives not
only of liebe but also of joy of course
and David
I understand that for Joy Marie arena is
now willing to step in but try to make
it in one minute and a half
thank you
I have three points I'd like to mention
first of all
we've mentioned this idea of camps which
might seem like a a humanitarian
solution that is efficient in the short
term
I was in Pakistan after the floods and
there was no solution then that the
choose to create emergency camps but too
often we see that camps are seen
as a way to keep populations under
control this is
the policy that we are doing here in the
EU when we keep refugees in camps and
this is also what is happening in third
countries so we need to look at
alternative methods to camps
how are they assessed and what is the
cost of using an alternative
just two days ago in the ACP Meeting
those countries were telling us that if
we called upon solidarity from local
communities it would cost a lot less to
the International Community so is has
there been any kind of assessment that
would show how we could be more
efficient and more Humane my second
question has to do with governance very
often we see displaced persons who come
from forgotten regions and they're kept
in other forgotten regions
we you mentioned that we need to look at
internally displaced people with a more
holistic point of view so how do you
make a link between
human the humanitarian approach and
development Aid so that we can be more
efficient and finally when it comes to
the consistency of our policies
in the inter-parliamentary meeting with
the ACP countries we also discussed that
we're going to have a law for the access
to critical minerals for Europeans and
that as we know will destabilize many
countries because
there will be land grabs and land grabs
means displacement of people it means
security issues so when we pass a loss
on critical raw materials
do we have an impact assessment on human
rights and displacements because and
what all this could entail for countries
in the medium and long term thank you
see
um
one and a half minutes please
thank you I'm going to speak in Germany
maybe that helps for the one and a half
minutes
um well
when we talk about this to bed we've got
the micro level and the macro level
we've heard a great deal about the micro
level but I think if we look at the
wider political situation you have to
look at the wider picture
we don't even want people to have to
flee their countries in the first place
we look at War and conflict as a core
because it can be poverty climate change
loving standards of living the labor
market many other factors that and we
look at these they're reflected in the
sustainability targets we're now at the
half point and we know very well that we
can do so much more we can do so much
better we haven't done our homework and
these are the Investments that actually
make it possible to avoid potential
um flight and people having to leave
now even though it's a world Refugee day
let's not forget those people who are
being prevented from fleeing who are
forced to stay in Conflict areas who are
forced to stay in these situations and
we can't
um forget these people we don't want to
forget their polite and that's millions
of people who are in that situation
if we come back to the micro level and
we're not talking only about managing
flows of people fleeing I know this
sounds very technical but also in those
regions where that you have conflicts
well yes there's the call for money
there's that's very uh frequently said
and I don't want to spend too much time
stressing that point but everything
going Beyond managing the humanitarian
crisis I know we've had
um this element managed in the opening
speech we need to think about involving
the local level better when it comes to
sanctions other policies we really need
to rethink our approach as and and kind
of move away from the standard approach
when it comes to Aid and development
support
I need to become be more pragmatic in
the way we handle these things that's my
wish it was
something well but she left so we moved
to the next street make it in one minute
and a half please thank you chair and
thanks a lot for the three speakers and
more specifically to uh Mr
bahati mingi because it was very
impressive also because he really shows
that protection is so much more than
only non-refilement protection is about
offering people a real chance to build a
new future to develop themselves to live
together with their family members and
to really ensure sustainable protection
and and to find themselves again and and
that would be the only way to give them
again their right to dignity back and
this is what we often forget when we
discuss about Refugee policies and and
I'm also very happy for the two other
speakers that also emphasize the need
for people to really develop themselves
and and and and give a having a new
future but if I look at the EU
performances the policies I really have
a lot of concerns about do we really
contribute to that sufficiently if I
think of the global compact on the
refugees where EU member states also
gave fully endorsement of the need to to
share the responsibility for refugees
worldwide and I see what is happening at
the moment where the EU is directing to
I see a huge mismatch and I see a huge
gap and and I wonder how we could get
out of that and and go into the
direction of really take an active part
in this responsibility for refugees
worldwide and I see really a tendency of
Shifting responsibility internally we
just pay off our responsibility to the
Border countries but also through the
deals that we conclude with third
countries uh and and of course it's
through a lot of development funding is
also going to displace persons but is
also more and more used for
agreements on migration cooperation
mainly focusing on border control and
returns and if I see but hopefully you
can rebut this but my impression is that
if you look at how the money is spent
the vast majority goes to those
restrictive measures instead of offering
and supporting people in this new future
and and access to education etc etc
maybe you can hopefully you have other
figures but this is my impression and
also the increasing use of
conditionality means that we make it
subject to their cooperation or returns
and Border controls instead of for
instance saying we offer substantial
funding
really enough and timely but please make
sure that people are not staying in the
protracted situation that they can
really develop themselves and of course
I see the constraints where there are
many refugees being hosted but access to
education we could support them in
funding it and to really make their life
worth more worthwhile
um I don't know how much time
you have doubled your dose so please
before before getting started try to
phrase your mind to a minute and a half
just it's a psychological exercise
psychological exercise I mean you know
you know that you cannot say State your
whole storytelling that you have to
encapsulate it to the shortest version
possible before before getting started
because I don't want to break in I want
to interrupt you but there's a list and
then we should be given the chance for
the three speakers in a row and the
commission which is also invited to have
some say after having heard of you so
please try to phrase your minds as to
one minute unhappy because if there's
three committees please before getting
started now we move on to Eric Marquardt
David yes but actually tinica also took
the time for the drug committee
and but yeah I would speak in German
um well
it's very important that we
draw attention
crises and that's only possible if we
are honest with ourselves and if we are
honest about what the situation is on
our external borders we can't really try
to hide what's going on there we can't
if we can't achieve
some visibility for the project if we
look at uh what's going on with the
Libyan coast guard for example then
it's going to be very difficult for us
to shed a light on what's going on in
Congo Yemen or elsewhere or in Syria for
example
it's going to be harder to resolve the
problems that exist elsewhere if we're
sending out a message from Europe that
protection for refugees is not at the
top of their gender for governments and
I think it has to be said that Refugee
law isn't in fact being protected by the
governments in member states it's it's
the courts that are still safeguarding
it and I think it's that's how Asylum
laws being safeguarded and I don't want
to get too drawn out in my explanation
of this but I do have a question for the
commission how can we make things more
transparent what is the European Union
doing with EU taxpayers money it's
extremely difficult for us as MEPS to
understand which projects are being
funded with which objective what the
outcomes are of the project and then you
know if we are racking our brains trying
to figure out what's being done what
money is going to then we can't be
surprised if citizens are confused oh
for the devil isior
I speak about the language
um
a very important debate and a very
much needed I've been here for 19 years
and this problem
has become a more and more of a
challenge for us as the EU and I want to
say that the biggest Refugee crisis in
Europe
is
an effect the consequence of Russian
invasion on Ukraine eight million of
ukrainians were looking for help and in
my country I think the biggest group of
refugees got such health and assistance
as many as 80 percent of polls were
directly involved in help by collecting
money giving help in kind even giving
their apartments or rooms in their homes
we have a situations where we have no
camps for refugees they live with poles
with
their apartments with the apartments
that have been rented for them and it's
worth saying that 190 000 children from
Ukraine is using free of charge for
using polish educational system and 1.5
million of ukrainians has an uh National
identification number the same as polish
citizens they can use all the Public
Services Social Services just like
polish citizens and the last thing one
last sentence we have spent 10 billion
euros for that we received from EU
funding uh around
200 million which is 100 Euros per head
and the new migration packed wants to
find US 20 000 Euros if for each migrant
that we do not take but this is a
strange solidarity for me
now I think we should hear from Madame
but she left
for 80. so we move on to Costa
salvaditis left
thank you chair
the two europes there is the Europe
that makes conclusions and the Europe
that does not understand Mr
christopoulos a professor in Athens had
said that we would have found the
solution to the refugee question if it
were a different question
Mr Bullman said that the borders should
be a meeting point and not the rejection
point
some people in my country would not
agree they would talk about treason they
would talk about
a problem and not about a dream or what
Mr Weber said that
fences are a taboo and
what I would like to say today since it
is we're talking about the world Refugee
day is it a day for refugees or against
refugees we should say something to
those people who have been lost people
in the shipwreck in githira or in Melia
what can we tell those people
when these people drown we state that
the problem is the Smugglers and we do
not state that Europe is a sponsor of
Smugglers this is hypocrisy we will be
here for one more year in our mandate
all Democratic forces should try and
convince citizens to do their best
because it is a real concern for me what
the next European parliament's
composition will be able to do
what will be the prevailing opinion in
the next parliamentary term will we help
the refugees or will we let them drown
thank you from some other members which
are attending and have us full floor
Mr sorrino
Carlos
thank you
president
we're not getting sound the interpreters
Mike
night is open
thank you we now have sound
been very very quickly now I will return
my presentation
thank you very much
chairman
dear colleagues
thank you for your presentations in 2023
we
expect that to 170 million people will
be forced to flee and 23.9
um
and it will be fleeing and children and
a week see these numbers are very
shocking
and we see there's a need to move away
people who are fleeing that everyday
situations to seek a better life now I
I'm very
speaking here
um
on behalf of those who are in forgotten
crisis forgotten Refugee situations and
we need measures and innovative
solutions for these people these are
very much needed and we need additional
funding we need
and we will propose new interventions
for humanitarian Aid and
the triple
Nexus now we're going to find
effective solutions to protect refugees
so that we can have people uh no one
being left behind
this exchange abuse today is an
important contribution to this and I
thank you for it it's very enriching and
it will help the parliament
in its work on the proposal it will vote
on by the end of this year now this
Parliament
has taken a very pertinent step today on
the world Refugee today
thank you chair and and I will speak in
Spanish please put on the head the
headphone
um gracias thank you very much thank you
once again to Mr bati for for his
testimony it's very very uh real this
experience of a refugee and I thank you
for the unit uh cr4 promoting this joint
meeting bringing three committees
together it's very pertinent for us to
hold this the things I'd like to propose
I think that it's very clear that the
refugee population is going to continue
to grow because of conflicts On The Rise
but also because of climate change and
the impact of climate change we have
every indication that 143 million people
will be forced to flee and cross borders
between now and 2050 and so the European
Parliament needs to recognize the link
between climate change and migration uh
second day we need to move towards
um definition of climate Refugee now I
know this is a Tom term it's a complex
that perhaps doesn't enjoy consensus but
amongst all uh people but I think it's
something we should try to achieve and
no other Parliament have done so in the
kanpala agreement in the African Empire
and then also in Latin America now we
need to increase the extent the
protection mechanism to include climate
now I know there's going to be some time
needed for us to achieve this to
understand which climate events would be
considered for this as having a
life-threatening nature different uh
European courts may be able to involve
for example the human rights Court of
the United Nations
we have a case with Seychelles and we're
from for someone from Bangladesh for
example but uh and also the Andaman
Island so we have a number of different
case law being developed
and
when it comes to the Forgotten crisis
the the I thank
the unit so far the presentation that we
heard it's we have three different
countries three political groups that
have come together to try and put
together an exhibition to draw people's
attention to the problem to this to the
pledge of Ukrainian but
um refugees but also we shouldn't forget
the many other countries that are in
crisis so thank you very much for
allowing me to speak
is there anyone else willing to
contribute to the discussion I would
like to miss any one of you
would you no stop would you no it's not
the case if it's not the case then we
turn back to our guest speakers we've
heard the the reactions absolutely moved
by the compelling testimonies we heard
of and of course concerned about this
forgotten this ongoing forgotten Christ
and what the European Union should do
about it certainly it should do better
certainly it should do better that is
for sure I mean that's the Common Ground
here there must be discussion as to on
which extent how far but anyhow it
should do better because uh that there
is there is a also a consensus that
simply denying facts or ignoring the
suffering which is underlying the the
trend of uh people expelled from the
countries where they were born in the
first place would lead us nowhere so we
hear from you now I suggest we turn back
to our speakers each
by one let's say
I am suggested three four minutes
maximum each of you getting started with
the first one Mr mizuni bahati minasi
bahati I don't know how to pronounce it
but please if you are connected
the floor is yours Mr bahati
yes uh thank you cheers once again and
uh thank you once again for this
opportunity because this opportunity
means a lot to me and it means a lot to
me in the sense that I'm not only
speaking for myself but I'm speaking for
many other people out there who are in
the same situation that I went through
that I am right now testifying and
actually representing for so for me the
most important thing that I feel is
something that can actually provide hope
to anyone who is displaced
and affected with this crisis
education for me has been a fundamental
tool and I believe that through
education many many young people who are
refugees can find Hope and can actually
be able to be
people who can
uh contribute greatly to their
communities even to the world
at large because today if we look in
History Albert Einstein was a refugee as
well but today Albert Einstein
scholarship Daffy scholarship is the one
actually helping many refugees to go to
higher tertiary education
so let us give
each and everyone in this world a chance
the human we are here in the world
we have only one race which is the human
race
we should all treat each other the same
and we should give each other a chance
to contribute in this world
there are many young talented people in
the refugee camps who can actually make
change and actually create even
employment for many people out there but
because they do not have a chance their
dreams are shattered their dreams and
are not are forgotten
so if these people get a chance their
nature then given the opportunity
to become what they ought to be
and to realize their Vision we can make
the world a better place
I thank you
again Mr bahati we really thank you
we're honored to have you among us and
we wish you well not only in your
master's degree in the rest of the life
uh waiting ahead of you and of course
you you made the right point you
representing on yourself but all of the
all of the all of the human beings that
are comprehended in your
experience of striving and surviving
so much so we thank you for that we
appreciate it Mrs Rockefeller the floor
goes to you three four minutes if you me
if you may
thank you very much chair and thank you
very much to all your compelling
statements
um
let me start maybe by the macro level
that uh
that one of you mentioned uh yes
responsibility sharing
is not about
um additional Finance financing only it
is about how to share responsibility
um in other ways as well
this is what I had pointed to before and
looking at a comprehensive protection
and solutions uh oriented manner that is
coherent globally
the needs are as you pointed out are
increasing
um 117 million projected to the end of
the year we have increasing numbers of
protracted Refugee situations
and more and more and proliferating
conflict situation and fragile context
uh and more financing and more
humanitarian response will not be
sufficient uh on its own so how do we go
about it and
um
we need to address root causes you
mentioned it as well if you look at the
figures 52 of all refugees and other
people in need of international
protection came only from three
countries so that is Syrian Arab
Republic Ukraine and Afghanistan so the
task at hand is large but it is also uh
there it's also contained to a certain
degree you can you can
you can directly see that
um in addition to addressing root causes
where the peace element comes in we have
to look at the humanitarian and
development
to gain a shared understanding of the
situation closest
to where displacement happens not wait
until we um until people
reach and pass through many countries
and and you know risk protection
uh uh protection challenges
[Music]
um
we have to
be and how do we do that further we have
to be more effective more efficient and
more more coherent I would like to
mention seven principles that the oecd
die cut came up uh with just in terms of
not just the principles but what does it
mean in uh in concrete terms
for example promoting and ending to uh
promoting a progressive Refugee policy
environment what does that mean
precisely working with national
authorities governments host communities
to ensure inclusion into policies we
have seen that in Colombia for example
where that has been taken forward very
progressively in terms of providing work
permits Etc to people fleeing Venezuela
adopting financing tools I spoke about
it to fit reality of populations what
does it mean precisely flexibility of of
budgets between National local levels uh
across regions very important supporting
local systems some of you mentioned it
at National systems directly through
financing at local levels very important
also
um
uh ensuring that people are refugees and
idps are reflected in the budgets be it
at National or local levels so that the
figures are there so that when support
is coming that it reaches them I've seen
it myself in Afghanistan in 2018
where for 40 years near a city
people idps have been living in a
settlement and 40 Years of water
Trucking has been ongoing in any
development project going towards that
will ever capture those people because
they were never recorded in the budget
in the local systems so a humanitarian
response cannot show to this
bring development peace intervention by
by default in addition to humanitarian
responses the global compact for
refugees is a good reflection of that
and promoting self-reliance for refugees
and idps now these are the seven
principles we need to be evidence-based
that was also uh referred to
um and look how we can uh work together
towards achieving this closest to where
displacement happens thank you
now Mr Luciani please mind the timing
because you know that the interpretation
coming is an essential condition for the
work we do here please do
thank you Chad thank you for all the
Torso that's intervened and for the
opportunity of this uh discussion and
and we look forward also to have
additional opportunities to exchange and
also to provide even more detailed
information on all what is been done and
needs to be done in to address the
forcing special situation indeed I mean
there is a lot of information that is
available and depending on the specific
interests we are ready and available in
writing or orally to come back and to
provide all this information
and I would like to stress also that
there is not a single Cent that is spent
by the commission without the European
Parliament knowing this well in advance
because under the cometology no action
documentation program no multi-annual
action program can be adopted by the
commission without the scrutiny of the
European Parliament uh taking place
um so but in any case of course there is
a lot of other information that are
relevant that can be shared when it
comes to the implementation of the
actions and we are ready to provide this
and of course we also struggle to know
all what's happening all over the places
because we are indeed a number of
actions more than 100 are already in the
pipeline or adopted in in all continents
so it's it's not an easy task but indeed
we are we are that's our work and we are
ready to do this I would like just to uh
react to one of the other points that
have been made the question of the
encampment and I would like to stress
once more time uh I had already said
this in my previous intervention that
encampment indeed takes place in the
context of the emergencies this is
frequently the response provided by
those delivered in the humanitarian
assistance the first support
but it's absolutely not the new policy
neither the commissioner foreign
together with other actors so to stop it
as soon as possible when it's clear that
the situation is protracted and there is
no possibility of an easy and quick
return on the contrary we push forward
the towards local integration uh
whenever it's possible which means
indeed the uh giving the possibility to
move from the campmans towards a normal
settlements and possibly also merging
into the local population and access is
given uh to uh education and death
through specific facilities in the
campmans when this is the only
possibility but otherwise the idea of
the development cooperation is exactly
to give ax help the host communities to
have reinforced social structures uh
such as schools hospitals to us to allow
refugees or idps to have access to the
normal hospitals normal schools so that
exist in in the US communities
frequently however the displaced persons
are hosted in regions where not even the
the native population has already
schools or hospitals so this is really a
straining and challenging but the idea
is of course to move from the camps as
soon as possible but then we should
never forget that we operate in the
third countries and they are Mastered on
their territory so we deal with
countries that decided that the refugee
tomorrow can live together with the
others compatriots and that encounters
that forbid getting getting out from the
camps and in some cases we have no
leverage to change their policy approach
and so we have to adapt ourselves and in
a continuous policy negotiation that
again accompanied the use of financial
resources and we also on that we work
together with our commissioner for
averages and the other donors so we
should be reminded the the importance of
our resource but also the limited impact
that we can have on the territory of the
others that frequently don't want uh to
to be more forthcoming
I think I can stop that thank you okay
and now before
concluding remarks from My Dear
co-chairs Mrs bresso and Mr Bullman I
would suggest that the commission would
have a chance to
make a comment and share a comment with
us the commission is
uh I was not going to intervene but
since I'm giving the flow a very short
um thank you very much chair no Rumble
members of of the parliament and uh
distinguished speakers maybe just to
react to about
what we do inside the European Union and
here I think we have a unique
opportunity now to try to get a European
migration and Asylum policy that is
equipped to deal with the challenges we
all are facing in the 21st century when
the commission put forward our proposal
the objective was really to give life to
articulating of the charter access to
the Asylum procedure and also to the uh
article 80 of the treaty the solidarity
and fair share of responsibility our
objective is to have Swift and efficient
access to the Asylum procedure a Humane
system that is fully respecting of
international obligations and
fundamental rights with a meaningful or
solidarity and a truly fair and
sustainable system for responsibility
and here is where we have to come
together with European strategy because
it's the only way the European Union can
face the challenges ahead the EU and the
commission is committed to ensure that
the EU remains a place where refugees
find protection and safety and now with
the institutional negotiations between
the European Parliament and the Council
on the different pieces of the part of
migration and Asylum we have now the
unique opportunity to have it might not
be the perfect system just replying to
what Mrs Santos said might know the
perfect system it might be the only
system we can have right now in the
current policy context but for sure I
think it will be better than what we
have today and it will help us all to
deal together with these challenges and
be better equipped and will be a step
forward and this is what I hope that to
in the future will be able to get more
integrated so look at this packed as the
step towards getting all together to
create this European strategy and to
give lives to some of this principles
that are essential another heart of the
treaty and the European values we all
withhold and we have the commitment of
both institutions the European
Parliament and the council as part of
the roadmap to get this done before the
the end of this mandate and you can
count of the European commission to do
its best to be its owner's broker to
bring both institutions together you are
far apart but there are many points of
uh in which you agree as well even if
sometimes it's not so obvious from the
text thank you very much it's worthy
giving you the floor Mrs possum for sure
it was worthy because because that is
there is a spirit of our side from the
European Parliament we have done a part
of the job we are truly committed to
strike a right balance
in the common Asylum system that is the
European goal
to be reached with the principles of
shared responsibility and solidarity
meaningful solidarity enforceable
solidarity obligatory solidarity binding
solidarity but meaningful solidarity and
effective solidarity for sure that is
depending that is the pending issue that
is the pending challenge so we're glad
we we heard from you because we are
counting of you as you have said as the
good mediator between the council and
the European Parliament we're just
getting started with the trilogs and we
we have a way to go but not much time
time is running out
and it's gonna be him this Monday this
is the last chance to make it right so
we only have the this this this this
meaningful purpose uh awaiting us to to
be delivered before before the European
elections because people are there
watching us watching over us and they're
they're they're they're
putting pressure on on every
representative directly elected to this
house and that is the way we see it our
duty so I I turned back the floor to
Mercedes
for the final remarks
well just a minute really I mean I fully
share
what our chairman has just said of
course
and let me just recall one aspect of all
of this I mean European funds for a
whole series
of reasons
uh uh ending up uh being spent in ways
that are then harder to scrutinize I
mean look at the global gateway for
example it's used for a whole series of
things but it basically makes it more
difficult for Parliament to scrutinize
what's being done with the funds so I
just wanted to
say that we shouldn't forget that the
parliament has a right to scrutiny and
that can't be undermined via policies
which we also share actually I mean
they're often the right choices being
made but they can't deprive the
parliament of its rights thank you
so thank you again thank you to all our
speakers uh for what you've told us
you've given us a lot of information
that's very useful thank you thanks Adam
Fernando and thanks colleagues for this
meeting once Miss Rockefeller for the uh
HCR is going to mention that more than
50 percent of refugees come from three
countries
uh mentioning Syria Ukraine and
Afghanistan we could feel tempted to get
in the question how come
because immediately we see that each of
these countries have a story
and we don't have the time today but uh
number one for me is that peacekeeping
and strengthening a multilateral system
is the best of all possible preventions
for uh people suffering on their long
way to other countries secondly when we
realize the new challenge of climate
change uh then we can immediately
conclude that Antonio Gutierrez agenda
2030 reform sustainable development
goals is the best prevention against
creating new
Refugee
problems because of environmental
disasters and thirdly
how well you say okay
our legal construction is better than in
most parts of the world
let's watch that we do not deviate
and where we got on the wrong track
let's repair that thank you
thank you it was quite a conversation
the one we had on the world Refugee day
we thank you all for your contributions
and not to abuse the time that the
interpretation covering has spared on us
we thank you and that will be it right
now the next meeting of the labor
committee will be taking place July 6
2023 by 9 00 am okay
bye now have a nice lunch